chaque collègue bonjour bonjour la
réunion d'aujourd'hui sera consacrée aux
questions de soutien à l'économie aux
entreprises à l'emploi et aux revenus
pour les citoyens dans le cadre de cette
épidémie de caunes un virus le
gouvernement a déjà pris des mesures qui
sont en cours
nous nous sommes mis d'accord pour
développer les aides et les mesures
supplémentaires et par conséquent je
considère que la liste des personnes et
des entreprises qui ont le plus souffert
que ce soit le tourisme l'hôtellerie les
loisirs et toutes les entreprises qui
sont dans le commerce non alimentaire
toutes ces entreprises connaissent
aujourd'hui des problèmes et je prie le
gouvernement de mettre en place les
différents dispositifs validé entre tous
les ministères premièrement apporté au
pm qui ont souffert des aides
supplémentaires à celles qui ont déjà
été adoptées avec une aide financière de
la part des états non remboursables ces
entreprises sont confrontées à des
difficultés immédiates à savoir le
paiement des salaires le maintien il est
salaire en avril et en mai le volume ni
kress de ces entreprises sera calculé en
fonction de leurs effectifs à la date du
1er avril de l'année en cours avec un
plafond de 100 130 mille roubles par
personne
cette mesure doit s'adapter de façon
facile pour les entreprises sans retard
et en même temps sans précipitation tout
cela doit être mise en place
donc à partir du 1er mai toutes ces
aides devraient pouvoir être accordé en
un mois le l'objectif prioritaire étant
de maintenir les effectifs des
entreprises
encore une fois à l'état du 1er avril
et si je cette mesure se met en place et
si effectivement le gouvernement
travaille là dessus
à ce moment là effectivement les aides
devraient intervenir pour avril vers le
18 mai et pour le mois de mai courant
juin je propose de mettre en place un
dispositif de crédit sur six mois sans
intérêt pour le paiement des salaires au
bénéfice des entreprises
aujourd'hui on voit que les banques ne
vont pas un ne font pas de geste en
faveur des entreprises et des personnes
et que aujourd'hui 70% des salaires ou
des crédits les hauts salaires doivent
être assurées par la banque venait chez
un homme en banque pour les entreprises
les autres les banques commerciales
celles ci doivent améliorer les
facilités d'accès aux aides aux
entreprises et cela concerne aussi les
entreprises de moyenne taille et de
grande taille pour que toutes les
entreprises puissent conserver leur
effectif et en même temps payer les
salaires troisième point en ce qui
concerne les entreprises
qui ont un rôle systémique dans notre
économie il s'agit ici de mener une
enquête sur des critères objectifs dans
la mesure où ce sont des entreprises qui
ont un intérêt pour l'ensemble de
l'économie nationale
je sais que des milliers de grandes
entreprises ont déjà fait partie sont
déjà font déjà partie des mesures
adoptées par le gouvernement mais il
s'agit de proposer des produits
financiers facilité pour ces entreprises
pour qu'elles puissent faire des achats
de matières premières et en même temps
pouvoir livrer les produits qu'il dit
qui leur ont été commandés cela concerne
aussi les relations avec leurs
partenaires
c'est à dire que nous soutenons l'emploi
et les entreprises mais nous voyons
ensuite à ce que l'ensemble de la chaîne
de distribution soit assurée les crédits
doivent être accordées dans la
fourchette 2 6% deux mois du haut niveau
du marché et dans les taux proposés par
la banque centrale
cela permettra de donner des stimulants
supplémentaires aux banques pour
accorder ce type de crédit quatrième
point
j'ai déjà parlé de la nécessité ou d'une
aide financière complémentaire pour les
régions
aujourd'hui on sait que les régions au
niveau régional un grand travail de
soutien aux entreprises est mené on sait
qu'il ya une charge financière qui est
très lourde et donc c'est ces régions
ont besoin de ressources supplémentaires
je demande donc
affecté 200 milliards de dollars
supplémentaires les entreprises doivent
pouvoir bénéficier d'une aide pour que
ces régions puissent assurer cette aide
aux entreprises à leur niveau encore une
fois au niveau des emplois et notamment
des fonctionnaires et d'apporter l'aide
sociale à l'ensemble de la population
chers collègues encore une fois je
respecte la situation évolue de façon
très rapide et je vous prie d'être en
lien permanent avec les régions les
différentes entités locales pour suivre
l'état de la situation
je suis convaincu que nous aurons besoin
de prendre d'autres mesures
complémentaires sur le plan économique
en général mais aussi sur le plan
sectoriel dans certains domaines il faut
consolider un certain nombre de
ressources qu'ils rendent déjà nous en
avons déjà parlé la semaine dernière
nous avons examen examiner la situation
dans certains secteurs comme le secteur
de la défense ou de l'espace et demain
nous tiendrons une réunion sur la
question du btp nous traiteront aussi
ultérieurement de l'automobile de
l'agriculture des constructions
aéronautiques et d'autres secteurs
industriels savent aujourd'hui que le
secteur des transports aériens
souffre particulièrement et il a aussi
besoin des aides supplémentaires à
hauteur de 23 milliards de roubles qu'il
s'agisse de leasing ou de soutien des
équipementiers aéronautiques et aussi il
ya la question du stationnement sur air
report des avions qui ne sont pas en
circulation je vous prie d'élaborer des
mesures très rapidement et de me
proposer ces mesures qui auront été
élaboré